[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soulas à grenade jours à sanaa
art
dennis k mais pas que parce qu'ils
viennent nous voir aussi pour un nouveau
spectacle fera à danse avec la stricte
puisque des gens dans la rue et on va
essayer de d'élire le meilleur danseur
de la gagne à deux secondes deux
secondes et regarder un arrêt à l appel
comment tu t'appelles ma chérie talent
est vendu 10 ou besoin de toi tu vas
monter sur scène là et tu vas dans cet
acte a reconnu maxime d'irène est lui
bien sûr y incite saladières comme on le
connaît et maxime gravel et d'une statue
du regard danse avec les stars regardant
sélectionnés sur la danse j'adore tous
alors tu l'appelles jules jurera pas mal
et tu es jeune tu as un vrai nom dieu
alors on y va et max et vous mettez sur
scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et c'est un génie ce maxime galets elle
sortait de chez elle perd elle était
encore pu s'en sortira car elle est en
train de faire une salle loubet à mon
frère avait quelques haltères pour ce
soir elle a eu on arrête comme ça je
sais que ce n'était pas dans la danse
bah pas du tout l'été avec des numéros
elle ferait danser un arbre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement faire
alors les danseurs à a
laissez moi rire maxime dérives et
denitsa ikonomova minova alors on est
venu faire les malins sur le plateau de
l'animal disent ah oui j'aurais ton avis
en tant que femme en tant que danseuse
professionnelle et en tant qu'ami j'ai
peur que tu penses de moi renouveau de
la danse a dit la vérité mais que tu me
verrez dans danse avec les stars
est ce que vous êtes pour que je fasse
danse avec les stars en candidat et avec
qui tu avances et toi avec un grand t
comme tajine
[Rires]
[Musique]